regardez on est à Las Vegas parce que
vous avez pris une énorme fuite et bien
il y a des endroits où ils viennent vous
passer des perfusions pour vous
permettre de vous réhydrater je trouve
ça complètement fou c'est là où on a une
culture qui est quand même différence au
niveau de la teuf c'est-à-dire que aux
États-Unis vous venez vous avez fait une
soirée de dingue alors nous en France on
est dans le mal on boit beaucoup d'eau
et on prend de doliprane d'ailleurs
faites attention de buvez pas l'alcool
est dangereux pour la santé mais eux ils
suivent non tu peux y aller il y a aucun
problème on va pas gâcher ta journée tu
viens dans un petit salon spécialisé on
te met une perfusion et c'est reparti
mon Tintin je trouve ça fou c'est une
vraie grosse différence alors une fois
de plus attention allez-y avec
modération mais c'est un problème que ça
me fait un peu rigoler voilà je vous
embrasse